You know my story, but not my name.
you know who i am... but not my journey
My name is PewDiePie,
Anime Hunter. You think I can't beat this stupid....
game?
fffffffuh!
I will not be defeated
by some cartoon ass lookin', bitch ass lookin' game! bitch ass looking game
Did I seriously died a hundred and seven times last episode?
Whatever!
WHATEVER!! ZERO DEATHS!!! IT DOESN'T COUNT!!!!
Here we go, I got it. I get it. I gotta ride Link. I gotta ride Link to the other side.
Okay, okay
YOU FUCKING ASSHOLE!!! Why, why did he do that? Then, what am I supposed to do? What a dick?! Link you're...
Don't... What the hell am I supposed to do then?
No! Where am I supposed to go?
What if I shoot him? Oh my god! Where do I go then?
Over here. Oh my god. Oh, I trick you, I trick you, Linky boy.
What the fuck?
*he's upset* *real upset*
I don't get it! Why is this game impossible?
I get it.
This is easy.
Right?
Fuck off. I need a sword, right? I need the fucking sword. You know what? Fuck this. I'm goin' back.
Fuck this I'm out.
Okay fine, I'll go back. Maybe I can walk on the spikes.
Maybe I can shoot the spike.
What the hell?
I broke the game.
I bro... I broke the... GOD DAMN IT! Oh my god. What do I doooooo?!
Okay, I get it. I get it. I get it. I get it.
Fuck off. It's a tricky jump, but I can do it
Fuck.
YES! YESS! FUCK YOU LINK, FUCK YOU!
*spits like a 3 year-old* *literally*
Fuck. It's so hard to time this jump.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Just let me go! Let me go! Am I gonna have to do this stupid jump every time?
I'm so fucking happy that this is happening.
Game broke again. What a great game? I love this. I love this. I live for this shit. Hell yeah!
This is so much fun. [mocking voice] 'Oooh,
ooh, game is hard. Too hard for you, Felix. You should go and play Pokemon.'
*some Swedish death curse*
Agghh!
That last spike, how do I [swedish bad word]?
How do I even? It's not even physically possible?
Go away, link!
What the hell am I supposed to do then?!
I have the power of God and anime on my side, can you jump if you jump off something?
I want to see this I can so I think I need to walk off him and then jump genius strategic
I know I've been playing a few games in my life look at me do this on the first try first try mother truckers
First try Bert shut up shut up second try zero deaths zero death fuck 0 that 0 deaths
First try first try zero death fuck Sarah to share that's the first trap for strap first strap
Watch me to your first try first right first right first right dad I?
first read zero death fuck it's the first try sir de
reserved
0.000000 fun y link I thought we loved each other
No
So close to do this limit. I can do this s way to battle the power of garden enemy
I will do this. I will conquer
9 9 f liner pine air because liner big designer
No no link no, what is happening with this a glitchy ass game
The beach fuck activate your Lourdes order
Whoa whoa what the what? Oh my god. I had it. This is so hard stop judging me
Ah
Link this is good da fuck you link give me the same. Hell yeah
That's what I'm talking about zero deaths, they're all death here, Oh, Oh
Easy game, it's easy this game is easy. Okay. Okay? What's gonna kill me now
I wonder what's going to give me. Oh, maybe the fans. Oh
No, maybe the spike is
No my gosh
Easy easy what else I don't know why I asked, I don't really don't know why I asked
Hey mister man oh if you goes up and down, okay?
Okay you go over easy. Oh my god. What is this? Uh?
Okay, okay, okay, of course of course how am I gonna do that if I can't even do it normal?
What I didn't even touch it why aren't you double jumping?
My god, it's not that hard you anime loving piece of shit. Oh my god do it
Man work a letter an nah come on Felix come on fuck
Stop touching it. What are you doing? What are you doing look? How much you have left god damn. This is so tricky
Okay, let's look at the pattern
Yeah, oh, no you really hit the pattern there you boy, you really did a good job there you fuckwit
Oh my god, they go faster, are you kidding me? Are you kidding me? How am I supposed to do that? Oh?
This is so hard. I don't even know how I made it here. What Oh?
Watch me dying watch me fucking die
I don't get it. I don't fucking get it
When do I go here there's like no space to move there's like no fucking space at all oh
My god here we are again here. We are again at the impossible yeah Wow
I don't even know what kills me like is there a spot I can stand there it seems oh
I'm pretty good at this bit now like I can do this part, but the thought there this I don't get on
Like where where how is it? Even physically possible to go through that fucking place?
How I don't understand like there's nowhere to go. I simply between them, but it's no time. There's just no time I
I Just don't get it man. I play this 500 fucking times. I thank you
I
Don't understand
Yes
Fuck
Yes, you saw it smooth. That was oh my god. Okay great. We just got to make it
We just gotta make it. We just gotta make it to the top
Okay, what's gonna happen the spikes are gonna shoot me oh no not the specs
Fuck you. Oh my god. What that?
I'm so fucking tired of this shit *END*